the only way to scale this rock face is
by following an almost invisible crack
these images from the documentary film
wideboys to show an extreme an
unconventional sport that demands power
stamina and an immunity to pain
I really like doing things that are
different from what other people like
doing so if people think it's a bad idea
that I should do crack climbing then I
think it's a good idea crack climbing
requires a lot of training
Tom Randall and Pete Whittaker spent a
lot of time in the Peak District in
northern England bandages are crucial
for avoiding hand injuries
and mastery of certain techniques is
also extremely important the wide boys
are constantly developing new ones to
make their climbs easier
people perceive it as being difficult
when they first do it they don't have
the techniques and then it can be really
painful and they'll probably end up
losing a lot of skin off their hands and
off their elbows and knees and then
they'll think it's a really horrible
experience and then they'll think it's
really difficult but actually when you
do it a little bit and you have the
right techniques and it can be just as
easy as doing normal coming after the
wideboys had acquired the right
techniques to master England's most
challenging cracks they decided to go
further afield three years ago they set
themselves the challenge of the century
crack in Utah or previously unclimbed
crack in a breathtaking environment
their exploit was documented in the film
why boys
ah
the width is an off size is it's a bad
size because when you try and fill the
crack with your body nothing quite fits
so you have to try and make up a lot of
techniques that you don't learn in the
early days of climbing and that's why
it's so hard and if even when you climb
it a lot it's still quite painful
the duo don't always train in the open
air to prepare for Utah's century crack
they spend two years practicing in their
basement after creating a purpose-built
climbing wall nowhere else
oh no other climbing walls obviously
have anything like this and it was
really important that we had something
specific that was exactly the same as
this climb because this climb hadn't
been done because it was so specific
really and so demanding in that sort of
style so we had to build this and
they've continued training in their
basement for the world's other
challenges since
and they also train in their garden this
is where they prepared for the Cobra
crack in Canada they recorded this
challenge in their second film wideboys
- it took several attempts before they
managed to master the 30 metre long
crack a spectacular achievement the
white boys always push themselves to the
limit we train really hard I sort of
always on this margin of actually
breaking ourselves training and then we
go outside and then it kind of all seems
okay because you push yourself so far
inside or training that everything
outside is kind of fun and lower
intensity and then you tend to succeed
on it next up is the legendary El
Capitan in Yosemite National Park the
vertical rock formation is over 1,000
meters high
they'll be hoping to break more records
and there may even be another film
you